From action flick to rom com, everyone has
that one movie that, no matter how many times
they've seen it before, they just can't resist
watching again.
Maybe it's the awesome plot, or amazing effects,
or maybe it's just one, singular scene that
draws people back in again and again.
What makes these scenes worthy of repeat viewings?
See for yourself.
Rosebud
With one whispered word, Orson Welles single
handedly invented the concept of the mind-blowing
twist ending.
"Rosebud."
Citizen Kane is considered by many to be the
greatest film ever made, and it holds up remarkably
well.
But it's the twist at the end that keeps viewers
coming back.
With his last dying breath, Charles Foster
Kane reminds us that despite the wealth and
power he has amassed, nothing can compare
to his innocent and happy childhood.
"I don't think any word can explain a man's
life.
No, I guess 'Rosebud' was just a piece in
a jigsaw puzzle."
The reveal of what Rosebud actually meant,
and the fact that no one in the world of the
film will ever understand it, comes as a profoundly
emotional shock.
"Rosebud...
It's his sled.
It was his sled from when he was a kid."
Considering how many times this film has been
parodied, there's no denying its cultural
imprint, especially in today's nostalgia-obsessed
climate.
"Brain…"
The shock of a lifetime
Jackie Chan is no stranger to death-defying
stunts.
The action star claims to have broken nearly
every bone in his body, and that's not hard
to believe if you've seen any of his movies.
But all his jumps, kicks, flips and flails
pale in comparison to his signature stunt
in Police Story.
Known as perhaps the greatest stunt in movie
history, it features Chan jumping off a balcony,
sliding down a pole, and crashing through
live electrical wires and plate glass.
The stunt is so iconic that the film shows
it three times in a row, from three different
angles.
Chan ended up electrocuting himself, dislocating
his pelvis, and cutting himself on the glass.
If this dedication isn't worth a few dozen
viewings, then NOTHING is.
Pool fantasies at Ridgemont High
In the history of cinema, no single moment
has turned more boys into men than Phoebe
Cates' slow-mo strut from the pool in Fast
Times at Ridgemont High.
It's pretty obvious why this is one of the
most rewatched scenes of all time.
"You know how cute i always thought you were."
And it's not just about a beautiful girl strutting
around in a bikini; it's funny, too!
After Brad's fantasy, the audience is then
shown to the cold, hard, embarrassing reality
of the situation.
For anyone who's ever been a teenager in love,
this scene is relatable, iconic, and totally
rewatchable.
A real trooper
No one understands better than George Lucas
how difficult it is to make a movie.
"But I did have a vision, but my vision was
way beyond what was possible.
And I did the best I could."
He did so many things wrong in his original
Star Wars trilogy that he went back in and
fixed them!
By fix we mean, of course, jam the movies
so full of special effects that audiences
can barely find any traces of the original
actors or sets in some scenes.
But one iconic scene was actually IMPROVED
by Lucas's meddling.
Decades of jokes have been made at the expense
of the poor stormtrooper who banged his head
on the doorway.
Lucas even added a "BONK" sound effect to
emphasize the moment for the special edition
release.
The whisper heard 'round the world
Lost in Translation was one of the most original
and oddly romantic movies to come out in years.
However, it left audiences scratching their
heads with its final scene.
Bill Murray's morose acting legend is saying
goodbye to Scarlett Johansson's lonely newlywed.
While they share a wonderful friendship, it
is clear that they'll never see each other
again.
Then, Murray leans in close and whispers something
in Johansson's ear.
You can hear that he's whispering, but what
he actually said was too quiet for the mics
to pick up.
There are tons of theories, but it looks like
whatever Murray said to Johansson is staying
between them.
Even director Sofia Coppola was kept in the
dark!
That mysterious whisper, and the rest of this
beautiful and poignant film, has kept audiences
coming back for over a decade.
A head-spinning ending
There is nothing more maddening than an ambiguous
ending, and no ambiguous ending was more maddening
than that of Inception, Christopher Nolan's
action/adventure dream heist.
As Leonardo DiCaprio's dream thief Dom Cobb
finally returns home to his children, he sets
a top spinning on the dining room table.
He runs off to greet his children, but the
camera goes back to the top, which was established
earlier in the film as a tool for Cobb to
tell whether he was awake or still dreaming.
If he was in a dream, the top would spin forever
without falling.
Just when the top is about to fall, the movie
cuts to black.
Nolan has never confirmed any of the extensive
fan theories that have come up.
Perhaps that's the point—trapping you in
an endless loop where you will never know
how the story ends.
Or maybe it's just a cool ending.
One morose Munchkin
Following the Yellow Brick Road sure is fun.
That is, until you get old enough to start
noticing what's dangling just through the
trees.
As familiar as The Wizard of Oz is to multiple
generations of fans, one aspect of the film
remained hidden to all but the most-eagle
eyed viewers.
For years, rumors circulated about a Munchkin
hanging in the background while our merry
band of travelers skipped into the distance.
The studio eventually denied this, claiming
that it was was just a bird.
When the remastered version was released in
1998, the rumor was debunked, as the figure
in the distance was, indeed, just a bird.
Still, stranger things have happened somewhere
over the rainbow...
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!